one of the things that happened during
the divisional round that didn't get a
whole lot of attention because we were
concerned about the team still playing
the cleveland browns hired their head
coach and the reward or punishment for
kevin stefanski for his performance on
saturday as offensive coordinator of the
vikings was to become the 18th coach of
the cleveland browns the announcement
came yesterday and peter it's funny when
you look at the statement from jimmy and
d haslem in what they're looking for in
a coach
basically they should have just said we
want the exact opposite of freddy
kitchens and now they have it in kevin
stefanski your thoughts on a guy who
really doesn't have much more experience
than kitchens did when he got the job a
year ago
well mike i think this is going to be a
great chemistry experiment in a new kind
of way of running the
a national football league team
and i think you know we all remember in
moneyball the art howe character who
never would accept
uh analytics or never would accept
playing what he felt were lesser players
who got on base all the time
instead of more big hitters okay and
that is going to be the test here mike i
see by your post on this issue
about uh you know about the browns
quarterback search you know that you've
talked to people who know things i think
i've talked to people who know things
and there's no question that this is
expected to be with kevin stefanski a
collaborative effort
to run the football side and the
football team between stefanski and uh
the guys who are going to work behind
the scenes in analytics and deep
football metric analysis
and
i i believe that there's quite a few
contenders
uh for this job but not only contenders
for this job but but others in football
who probably would not have wanted to
work under these circumstances stefanski
obviously accepts it
and peter from the standpoint of having
harmony and cooperation and
minimal dysfunction within the browns
organization i like the idea that chief
strategy officer paul d podesta
basically made this higher let him if
you're going to give him the influence
let him pick the coach because the worst
case you could have is is this ongoing
rivalry and tug of war and friction and
finger pointing in the organization
between the football guys and the
analytics guys get everybody on the same
page and see if it works i think that's
a good thing but here's the other side
of it if this doesn't work at some point
d podesta has to be as accountable as
john dorsey freddie kitchens anyone else
who's been fired by jimmy haslam and if
giving d podesta the power to hire who
he wants and set the table the way he
wants it if it does not work then the
next time they hit the reset button they
need to reset entirely and completely
and deep podesta has to have that same
accountability that anyone else would
have i think it's only fair if it works
great if it doesn't then it's time for a
new approach all together this is this
is a great litmus test of whether or not
this approach is going to work because
finally after four years everybody's on
the same page
well mike i'm not sure that that's true
and i'll tell you why um because jimmy
haslam when whenever he has his press
conference is going to be asked about
this and he's going to vehemently say
this is my decision this was not paul d
podesta's decision he had uh definitely
had a say in it but this was not his
decision it was mine
and right well but it's just peter it's
his decision
paul de paul let me say something paul d
podesta had the keys to the search paul
d podesta i'm told by multiple sources
was talking to people who were never
even interviewed he was screening and
deciding and picking who gets put in
front of the person who's making the
decision and the person who sets the
table with the options has so much power
over the process and if if if paul d
podesta has the ability to constantly
whisper in the year of jimmy haslam and
influence him it doesn't take much to
get him to hire kevin stefanski i think
paul di podesta had but how did that
play over this but
but mike the last two coaches
paul d podesta lost on
so you're saying
in your world in your theory okay so he
gets one coach now and then he gets
fired what about all the traditionalists
who have been picking coaches there
forever and who are still working i mean
that's why i don't buy what you're
saying
i don't buy that if stefanski goes three
and 13 the next two years
and again we don't know how it's going
to play out we just simply don't know
but i do believe that there is enough
i mean look he inter they interviewed
traditional guys who everybody in the
league was interested in not just uh
guys who only paul d podesta was
interested in you know there's no
evidence to me that they eliminated guys
before the cert now maybe they did
but i haven't heard evidence that they
eliminated the guys because d podesta
whispered in haslem's ear oh he's a
dinosaur jimmy we don't want him
i just think that deep podesta finally
got the chance to hire the guy he wanted
and again i support that because there
has been a poisonous atmosphere within
the browns organization during this four
years of analytics and football trying
to jam together it is far from a
chocolate peanut butter situation at
least in cleveland so it has resulted in
a revolving door with deep podesta never
being the guy who goes down but it's
been the other guys the football guys
the sashi browns the john dorsey's the
coaches they hired who are out my point
is if you're gonna let deep podesta who
successfully won every stare down with
everyone he came up against since he's
been there if he's in charge fine you're
in charge and if it works you get all
the rewards that go along with it and if
it doesn't you get the same outcome that
everybody else who's been fired by the
browns has gotten and look it's harsh
but it's reality in the nfl when there
are 32 teams who are constantly
competing with each other they're going
to be good teams they're going to be bad
teams and if the browns don't break the
cycle of being a bad team with deep
podesta picking his guy then i think he
suffers the same fate that we saw sashi
brown and john dorsey suffer
did he win the stare down on freddy
kitchens no did he win down on hugh
jackson no he did but peter he's still
employed everybody else was fired
you just win he won you just
you just said
you just said that paul d podesta has
won every stare down he's ever come up
the two biggest ones before this one he
lost
now how can you say he's won every stare
down i'm talking about the real stare
down i'm talking about i'm talking about
guns not knives i'm talking about the
headscarf it's not a real stare down no
peter i'm talking about employment all
these other guys got fired deep podesta
is still there so when he loses the
battle and wins the war loses the battle
wins the war he's won all the wars he's
lost some battles and because those guys
ended up being crappy coaches it allowed
him to win the war he's still employed
that's my point it's a very simple
concept d podesta is now in the
spotlight even though he's part-time and
he refuses to move to cleveland he's in
the spotlight he's the guy he picks
stefanski if this goes sideways or stays
sideways as the case may be i think they
need to flush it and start over again
and come up with a new approach and if
it works great but if it doesn't it's
time for the browns to have a new
approach and some fans would say if it
doesn't it's time for the browns to have
new ownership but good luck making that
happen
yeah i would just say let's see what
happens i'm as dubious about
uh the football analytics people
uh pouring over a game plan on friday or
saturday and saying we like this call we
don't like this call
that
that really kind of eliminates and look
mike
i am a firm
firm believer in analytics you know it's
one of the reasons why the baltimore
ravens for instance like pro football
focus
says and believes adamantly
that pass coverage guys because of their
scarcity are much more valuable than
past rush guys it's why the baltimore
ravens to make it very simple let go of
zadarius smith
and chose to keep marcus peters even
though marcus peters at times has been a
very disruptive guy in locker rooms
they did that because they believe in
past coverage so i believe that
analytics is vitally vitally important
to the success of a team
now having said that i'm not sure that i
want my analytics guys sitting in there
in the with the with the coach on
saturday night saying okay we've
analyzed the 220 plays in your game plan
on offense this week and the following
115 we don't like so we strongly
recommend that you kill them
that i don't like but i do recommend
that those guys be able to say hey coach
these are the ones that we believe have
the best chance to succeed
peter if you owned a football team would
you hire kevin stefanski or josh
mcdaniels to be the coach
josh mcdaniels
why do you think the browns didn't hire
him
i don't know the answer to that but i
know that last year at this time
kevin stefanski was a beloved guy by
some people in that cleveland building
including paul d podesta
from everything that i've heard
so you know that's i assume that's why
he got the job
but i also am not sure
that you know when they interviewed josh
mcdaniels what did he say
about this process that they were
planning to use with the head coach
would he i found it really interesting
that josh mcdaniels and his wife
got on a plane to cleveland
when does your wife usually come on a
job interview
when it's expected you're going to get
the job so i'd like to know what
happened during that interview what was
said what vibes were given off and i
don't know the answer to that and i also
don't know if they were going to hire
mcdaniels anyway over stefanski because
clearly after last year's process
they like stefanski a lot
so i can't answer what happened last
thursday in that meeting the one thing i
can say is that
if it were me and it were a clean slate
i'd hire josh mcdaniels in a second i
think he's a terrific coach
and
uh i think what has happened to him
is that he is getting black marked for
what happened in denver a decade ago
when he was about 19 years old
and he's getting black mark because he
turned down the colts now i totally get
that one i get it he accepted the job
and then he turned his back on it after
the super bowl that year so i get it if
you say look i'm not going to hire you
because of that but then don't interview
him you know once you've interviewed him
and brought his wife to town it's
obviously you've done your due diligence
and you have basically accepted the fact
that maybe they were extenuating
circumstances that led to him turning
down indianapolis
peter i firmly believe based upon
everything i've seen everything i've
heard
that if josh mcdaniels had gone in there
and said yes i'm okay with that yes i'm
okay with that yes i'm okay with that to
everything that kevin stefanski said yes
i'm okay with that too josh mcdaniels
would have been the head coach of the
cleveland browns it comes down to very
simply stiffness
isn't willing to do everything that deep
podesta and haslam want
and mcdaniels you know hey you either
want me to coach the team or you don't
bottom line
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports